[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres de l'actualité cet après-midi
mille élèves d'elancourt ont eu le
privilège d'échanger en direct de la
station spatiale internationale avec
l'astronaute français thomas pesquet
nous étions sur place à l'occasion de la
semaine des médias qui se déroule du 20
au 25 mars vous proposons de faire un
point dans les yvelines
le premier épisode est consacré à la
défiance des français face aux médias et
puis c'est une première en france neuf
ans après le dernier volet d'harry
potter une boutique consacrée
exclusivement aux jeunes sorciers en
d'ouvrir à versailles
une vraie caverne d'ali baba pour les
fans à découvrir dans ce journal
c'est un grand pas pour les 1000 élèves
d'elancourt
cet après midi ils ont pu échanger avec
l'astronaute français thomas pesquet
lors d'une conférence interactive en
direct de la station spatiale
internationale il a répondu aux
questions des écoliers préparé avec
leurs enseignants écoutez alma vie cruz
directrice de l'école de la ville duels
j'aimerais qu'ils retiennent l'énorme
progrès technologique que constitue l'
avantage qu'ils ont et j'aimerais aussi
qu il qu'ils aient en tête que tout ce
qui concerne le
le développement durable et en
particulier les problèmes vis à dos donc
des questions économiques des questions
écologiques et des questions de
développement durable et la course à la
présidentielle continue malgré la
tempête lee ho pénélope gates françois
fillon trace son chemin une réunion
publique de son soutien au candidat est
organisée à 20h à rambouillet seront
présents bruno retailleau sénateur de
vendée jean frédéric poisson député des
yvelines ou encore gérard larcher
à l'occasion de la semaine de la presse
du 20 au 25 mars nous vous proposons de
faire un point sur les médias dans les
yvelines
selon un sondage paru le mois dernier
les français se détournent des médias
traditionnels
seuls 41% d'entre eux fois encore
confiance à la télévision soit une
baisse de 9 pour de confiance par
rapport à 2016 et la radio est à 50 2 %
avec 3 pour trois points perdus
reportage selon un sondage kantar pour
le quotidien la croix 67% des personnes
interrogées jugent que les journalistes
ne sont pas indépendants des pressions
des partis politiques et du pouvoir je
pense que les médias nous disent qu'on a
envie d'entendre et ne disent pas
forcément tous mais c'est quand même une
bonne façon de connaître l'actualité de
savoir ce qui se passe dans le monde à
cause des meilleurs c'est le bordel dans
le sud est y stigmatise un peu trop je
trouve ils sont passés dans la réalité
dans le vrai juste le potage
l'impression alors qu'avant et c'était
chaud qui s'était un peu plus dans la
réalité
internet a considérablement changé les
habitudes des français 35% d'entre eux
recherchent l'information sur internet
et les réseaux sociaux
un changement au comportement qui a
poussé la population à s'informer
autrement je crois qu'il faut davantage
d'éducation à l'image de l'éducation aux
médias pour qu'on ne soit pas
prisonnier de forme de propagande qui
sont complètement délétère mais ça ça
n'est pas fait nous ça n'est pas fait
suffisamment geravand les médias c'était
simple et la presse écrite c'était la
radio c'était la télévision et s'était
fait par des journalistes
aujourd'hui on a des médias sans filtre
sans médiation et même si les
journalistes essayent de s'infiltrer sur
les réseaux sociaux pour décoder
l'information pour faire leur travail en
fait ça ne marche pas parce que c'est
trop instantanée ses troupes et normes
etc
pour christian delporte la seule
solution pour retrouver la confiance des
français doit passer par le retour aux
fondamentaux du journalisme
le journalisme c'est d'abord un
journalisme d'enquêté et enquête
ça passe par des protocoles ça passe par
la vérification le recoupement
d'informations et et ça passe aussi par
le fait qu'on ne lâche ne voit pas la
chose à faire on doit continuer à
travailler dans ce sens ça ne doit pas
être ponctuel
ce qui surprend parfois c'est pour ça
qu'on parle d' emballement médiatique à
propos d' enquête c'est qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de ces enquêtes et bien le
journaliste doit enquêter en permanence
c'est son travail des fondamentaux que
les élèves découvriront tout au long de
la semaine de la presse et des médias
qui se déroule du 20 au 25 mars
nous vous en parlions jeudi dernier le
lycée hôtelier de saint quentin en
yvelines accueillait la finale du
trophée du club des directeurs de la
restauration et d'exploitation le saint
quentinois match à guilliers élève en
deuxième année de bts a terminé à la
troisième place du concours il ya 55 ans
la guerre d'algérie prenez francs à
l'occasion de la journée nationale du
souvenir trap a rendu hommage aux
victimes
le maire de la ville guy malandain a lui
même combattu dans les rangs français un
reportage d'anne laure l'anguille à une
vingtaine de personnes se sont
rassemblées samedi face à la mairie de
trappes pour se souvenir des victimes de
l'algérie on estime le coût humain de ce
conflit à 30000 morts dans l'armée
française et entre 300 mille quatre cent
mille victimes côté algérien attrape
nous avons davantage d'avoir été suivi
par par la mairie et le conseil
municipal depuis le début et on a
toujours commémorer le 19 mars la fin de
la guerre d'algérie
d'ailleurs on a une stèle ici pour le
maire de la ville guy malandain lui-même
ancien combattant la cérémonie a une
résonance particulière à titre personnel
c'est une époque que j'ai connu mettez
vingt vingt neuf mois en algérie comme
tous les jeunes gens de l'époque
l'annoncent que c'était fini on pouvait
revenir à la maison il y avait pu y
avait plus de risques nous le
commémorons chaque année avec beaucoup
de beaucoup d'émotion récemment les
années coloniales ont refait surface
dans l'actualité
plusieurs candidats à la prochaine
élection présidentielle ont exprimé des
points de vue divergent quant à la
qualification de cette période
le maire de trappes a de son côté
demandé plus de fraternité entre les
peuples
mais ce qui est important c'est que les
peuples se parlent s'expliquent essaie
de se comprendre et bâtissent ensemble
quelque chose de positif
l'algérie fait partie des derniers pays
de l'ancien empire colonial français à
avoir recouvré son indépendance
on ouvre une page d'histoire avec ce
mariage celui de deux américains célébré
en 1944 durant la seconde guerre
mondiale à la chapelle royale du château
de versailles leur nièce était dans la
cité royale la semaine dernière pour
découvrir les archives de cette
cérémonie
c'est une petite histoire au coeur de la
grande
maureen hargrove est américaine elle
découvre la chapelle royale du château
de versailles
c'est ici qu'un mariage a marqué son
histoire familiale de pride of my touch
la mariée était la petite soeur de mon
père le marié était l'homme dont elle
est tombée amoureuse en afrique du nord
il est l ordonnance personnel du général
eisenhower et elle son chauffeur nous
connaissions cette histoire parce qu'il
a écrit un livre intitulé sergente micky
et general electric
le 16 décembre 1944 michael matthews et
parler à oreille se disent oui en
présence du général eisenhower une
célébration inscrits dans les archives
du château
ce mariage est tout à fait exceptionnel
en fait il est probablement le seul et
l'unique après le mariage de du futur
louis saez et de marie antoinette en
1770 donc c'était vraiment un événement
exceptionnel est qui et qui se légitime
par le fait que les américains étaient
positionnés au trianon palace et donc
libérez évidemment la france et l'europe
et les jeunes mariés ont ensuite passé
leur lune de miel à paris noreen rail
continue ses recherches
sa prochaine étape amsterdam la 10e
édition de l'eco-trail ce samedi au
départ de lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines la compétition
affiché une nouvelle fois complet plus
2500 coureurs se sont inscrits pour
cette course de 80 km avec 2300 mètres
de dénivelé avec un final au premier
étage de la tour eiffel on écoute les
participants au micro de nicolas landry
alors je participe à cette course parce
que je veux plutôt un coureur coureurs
de trail et en ile de france et le
c'est un des plus anciens trail qui a
été créée et donc c'est la 10e édition
donc là j'ai à coeur de présenter moi
pour cette dixième édition voilà j'ai
fait j'ai fait j'ai fini les nôtres
première édition alors cette compétition
moi je les adore parce que c'est une
compétition en version locale puisque
j'habite voisins le bretonneux
le format est très sympathique puisqu'il
ya quand même beaucoup de nature même si
l'arrivée est plus compliqué même si
plus roulante sur le bitume mais sur le
principe vraiment apprécié à quoi plus
de neuf ans après le dernier volet volet
d'harry potter une boutique consacré
presque exclusivement à la saga du jeune
sorcier vient de s'ouvrir à versailles
dans ce coup de l'art versailles et on
retrouve des baguettes des figurines ou
encore des ballets les détails avec nous
deux magiciens michael et demi d'euros
et nicolas landry la saga harry potter
s'invite à versailles une boutique
spécialisée s'est ouverte début février
à côté du vieux marché de la ville je
vais ouvrir les portes de cette
mystérieuse boutiques et j'espère que la
magie va opérer
[Musique]
je suis avec frédéric le gérant de cette
boutique alors frédéric pourquoi avoir
créé cet univers harry potter ici à
versailles alors tout d'abord c'est que
moi je suis déjà fan d'harry potter et
des animaux fantastiques et de l'auteure
jk rowling c'est compliqué pour les fans
de trouver en fait des objets au même
endroit
donc pourquoi ne pas avoir créé ma
propre boutique et trouver mon pauvre
aussi du coup mes objets et propose aux
fans en fait de trouver les objets
d'harry potter au même endroit et pas
faire dix mille magasins aux commandes
et une fois sur internet
[Musique]
e
frédéric je vois que vous avez quelques
petites baguettes juste derrière vous
alors voilà est-ce que vous me
conseillez une baguette en particulier
alors à la base c'est la baguette qui
choisit son sorcier mais on va peut-être
tenté le coup avec une baguette de queen
ingolsheim animaux fantastiques c'est un
peu une foldingue ou qu'une petite femme
un peu apprêtée chose comme ça donc tu
peux faire le geste et puis voir si
quelque chose se soulève c'est le
sorcier wingardium leviosa wingardium
leviosa wingardium leviosa pas leviosa
bon je vais tenter ça ou de garde youm
leviosa ah bah non il n'y a rien qui
s'est soulevée donc effectivement c'est
pas forcément une baguette qui est fait
pour toi
je suis juste un moldu pas forcément on
va voir si le choixpeau peut-être
décerner une maison d'un green team
cravate de chez poufsouffle on va
regarder avec le chapeau qui est juste
derrière moi alors le choixpeau est
choisi en fait la maison où tu vas aller
donc on va bien voir essayer
je sais dit voilà qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent à l'aï dit pas grand chose
donc peut-être qu'effectivement tu
resteras un moldu oublié
merci d'avoir fait réapparaître c'est
normal c'est normal oui c'est normal
alors quelles sont les grandes dates à
retenir pour votre magasin alors on fait
devient un acteur le 27 mai prochain
mais pour l'instant on va juste un
indice c'est que c'est un rouquin c'est
tout c'est tout pas n'ont pour l'instant
pas de nom
on attend ça avec impatience en tout cas
merci beaucoup et le journal se referme
sur 7 pts de magie on se retrouve demain
pour une nouvelle édition de 7,8 le
journal bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]